اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام بين النيتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي تتقلب الازمه شرقيه
المتوسط وسط مؤشرات للتهدئه واخرى ترجح
استمرارها في المستقبل حلف شمال الاطلسي
اعلن التوصل الى تفاهمات تركيه يونانيه
محورها اليه لتجنب النزاعات وفضها ومجالها
التحركات العسكريه الميدانيه في الاساس
اما الاتحاد الاوروبي فقد تداعت دوله ال7
الى قمه في بروكسل هيمن على اجندتها
التصعيد بين اثنا وانقره والموقف من
السياسات التركيه في ذلك الملف وغيره قمه
استبقت ها باريس بالدعوه الى اتخاذ موقف
حازم تجاه تركيا بينما بدت برلين اميل الى
موقف معتدل يستبعد منطق العقوبات في
التعاطي معها تقرير وليد
العطار هل ينزع النيتو فتيل الازمه تحت
سقف حلف شمال الاطلسي توصلت تركيا
واليونان اخيرا الى اتفاق هو الاول منذ
تفاقمت ازمه شرق المتوسط قبل اسابيع منذره
بتصعيد عسكري ست جولات من المفاوضات
الثنائيه في مقر النيتو ببروكسل اسفرت عن
اتفاق بشان اليه عسكريه تركيه يونانيه وخط
ساخن لحل نزاعات بهدف تقليل المخاطر
والمواجهات في المنطقه المحتقنه وزاره
الدفاع التركيه اضافت ان الخامسه من
اكتوبر الجاري سيشهد اجتماعا جديدا
لمناقشه اليه التنسيق المتعلقه بتوفير وسط
امن للعناصر العسكريه في المناطق المعنيه
التطور الاخير يتزامن مع انطلاق قمه
استثنائيه للاتحاد الاحادي الاوروبي في
بروكسل ايضا تستمر يومين واضعه على راس
اجندتها الازمه اليونانيه التركيه في شرق
المتوسط ولكن بنفس يبدو مختلفا عن اجواء
محادثات الجانبين في النيتو ينخرط القاده
الاوروبيون في قمتهم بدعم لا يخفى لليونان
وقبرص ضد تركيا واستبق مسؤولون اوروبيون
القمه بالتاكيد على ان كل الخيارات مطروحه
في مواجهه تركيا وخرجت تصريحات فرنسيه
تلوح بعقوبات محتمله ضد انقره وهو ما سارع
الجانب الالماني بنفيه مشددا على اهميه
التعاون الاوروبي التركي وفق ما قالت
المستشاره الالمانيه انجلا ميركل في وقت
سابق طوال الازمه لم يخفي الاتراك
امتعاضهم مما اعتبروه انحيازا اوروبيا
لليونان وقبرص وعشيه القمه قال الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان الجارتين
المذكورتين هما سبب المشاكل لا تركيا رفضت
اليونان ومن خلفها الاتحاد الاوروبي اعمال
التنقيب التركي عن الغاز فيما تقول انقره
انها مناطقها الخالصه وان الترسيم الذي
تتبناه اليونان جائر على الحق التركي يقول
مراقبون ان النزاعات على الحدود البحريه
بشكل خاص تستغرق جهدا ووقتا طويلين لحل
عقدها وتشابكات فهل يوفر الاتفاق التركي
اليوناني الجديد مناخا هادئا لمباحثات
طويله تنهي الجدل حول الحدود المائيه بين
الجانبين ام ان اطرافا اوروبيه قد ترغب في
اطاله ر الازمه لتوظيفها في الضغط على
الجانب التركي الذي حذر اليونان مما
اعتبره تحريضا
ضده ارحب بضيفي الذين انضما الي في هذا
النقاش من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
جوركان زينن ومن برلين دكتور جونتر زيفرت
رئيس مركز الدراسات التركيه التطبيقيه
بالمعهد الالماني للشؤون الدوليه والامنيه
مرحبا بكما وسؤالنا للسيد جوركان في
تقديرك ما اهميه الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل
اليه في محادثات
النيتو نعم انه مهم ولكنه ليس مهما جدا
ربما
اهميته تاتي من تقليل احتمالي ومخاطر اي
صدام عسكري بين القوات التركيه واليونانيه
هذا امر طيب لكنه اتفاق لن يحل كل
المشكلات لان تركيا مصره على موقفها في
التنقيب عن الغاز والنفط في الشرق المتوسط
وهذا حقه الطبيعي فنام انها عندما تقوم
بذلك لن يكون هناك صدام
بين الجيشين التركي
واليوناني اذا هذا امر جيد ان يكون هناك
نوع من تقليل حده التوتر واحتماليه الصدام
بين الطرفين طبعا افهم ان هناك اتفاقا
لخلق اليه ما وايجاد خط ساخن بين انقره
واثنا امر طيب لكنه لن يحل كل
المشكلات دكتور جونتر زيفرت يعني كيف
بتقديرك ايضا ينظر الاوروبيون الى هذا
التطور القادم من اروقه النيتو وهم
يباشرون قمتهم في
بروكسل
اتقد ان من الطبيعي ان الاوروبيين هم ايضا
يرحبون بهذا الانتخاب هو ليس اليه فض
نزاعات حقيقه بل اكث هو اليه لتفادي
صدامات غير مقصوده عسكريا بين الطرفين
طبعا التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق بحد ذاته
يظهر لي ان تركيا اتخذت خطوه الى الوراء
وتذكروا ان الاسطول التركي كان هو الذي
ابحر الى داخل مناطق متنازع عليها وكان
هناك شعور بان تركيا لن تتخذ اي خطوات الى
الوراء ولا حتى خطوه واحده لكنها الان
تقدم على هذه الخطه لتفادي اي اشتباك وهو
امر افضل مما كنا نتوقع قبل اسبوع من الان
بتقديرك ايضا كيف نفسر هذا التباين بين
الموقفين الالماني والفرنسي حيال
تركيا اعتقد ان هذا امرا ليس بال المفاجئ
حقيقه اولا نعلم ان المانيا وتركيا بينهما
علاقات خاصه جدا
ومميزه وعلى المستوى الاجتماعي لدينا عدد
كبير من المهاجرين الاتراك الذين هاجروا
الى المانيا وكلا البلدين طورا علاقات
تجاريه بينهما اذا هناك اعتماد متبادل بين
البلدين وكلا الحكومتين تحاولان الابقاء
على العلاقات الطيبه بينهما بالنسبه
لفرنسا القضيه مختلفه قليلا لان لدى فرنسا
مصالح اخرى مصالحها تنصب على ليبيا ومناطق
اخرى اكثر مما لدى المانيا من هذا من هذه
البلدان لهذا السبب موقف موقفها يختلف حول
هذا النزاع ايضا فرنسا والمانيا لم تنسق
بينهما طيله هذه الازمه وايضا كان هناك
تشابه من حيث ال
المفاوضات وضرورتها وايضا من حيث الحضور
العسكري التركي في المنطقه وهذا الذي اقنع
تركيا في النهايه بالقبول
بالمفاوضات سيد جوركان وزير الخارجيه
التركي اتهم باريس بالسعي لاضعاف حلف شمال
الاطلسي النيتو
وجهوده او جهوده في في حل هذه الازمه كيف
تقيم الموق الفرنسي حيال ما تم التوصل
اليه في النيتو وكذلك حيال ما يجري في
القمه الاوروبيه في
بروكسل كما قال ضيفكم في برلين الوضع من
حيث العلاقات
بين فرنسا وتركيا مختلفه تماما عن علاقات
ترك
والمانيا فرنسا لديها مشكله مع تركيا ليس
حول المتوسط بل حول افريقيا وليبيا وقبرص
لماذا لان تركيا وسعت من تواجدها وحضورها
في افريقيا على مدى العشر سنوات الماضيه
وهذا ما ازعج فرنسا باعتبارها قوه
استعماريه سابقه في افريقيا ايضا تركيا
وسعت من علاقاتها التجاريه مع افريقيا
وهذا ما فرنسا ايضا ثانيا فيما يتعلق
بليبيا ف
مثلا فرنسا هي عضو دائم في الامم المتحده
والسراج هي الحكومه الشرعيه لكن فرنسا
تدعم امير الحرب حفتر والذي لا يمثل
الحكومه الشرعيه تدعمه
و
وج ولكن بقاء حكومه السراج في الحكم على
عكس رغبتها
ازعجها الجزء الثالث او السبب الثالث
يتعلق
بقبرص
وال الاتفاقيات التي وقعت مع شركات فرنسيه
مثل توتال وغيرها انقره لا تعترف بترسيم
الحدود هذا والمنطقه الاقتصاديه ومع الامر
فيما يتعلق بليبيا الامم
المتحده
قبل ساعتين نحو ذلك
وثقت الامم المتحده الاتفاقيه بين تركيا
وليبيا كل هذا اساء الى العلاقه وفاقم
الاوضاع سوءا بين تركيا
وفرنسا فتقوم اذا فرنسا باستخدام اليونان
كاداه في خلافها مع تركيا المشكله
الرئيسيه لا تكمن بين تركيا واليونان بل
هي في الحقيقه بين تركيا وفرنسا في شرق
المتوسط دكتور جونتر الرئيس التركي اعتبر
ان العلاقات التركيه الاوروبيه تمر في هذه
الفتره بامتحان كبير كيف تتوقع ان تكون
نتيجه هذا الامتحان او هذا الاختبار في
ضوء القمه الاوروبيه في
بروكسل
اقول ان علينا ان نشدد على قضيه ان الضيف
التركي الشدد كثيرا على الخلاف
بين فرنسا والمانيا لكن من حيث المبدا
وفيما يتعلق بترسيم الحدود البحريه بين
فرنسا والمانيا ليس
مختلفا المانيا وفرنسا وكل الاتحاد
الاوروبي ادان الاعمال الاحاديه من جانب
تركيا في الشرق المتوسط اذا الخلاف في
الوسائل وليس على المبدا وعلينا ان نذكر
ايضا ان كل هذا الحديث عن عقوبات ضد تركيا
موجود حتى ولو كان بادنى مستوياته الرمزيه
كما ان هناك خوف من
ان او مخاف داخل تركيا من احتمال لفرض
عقوبات اوروبيه عليها وهذا الذي اجبر
تركيا على التراجع في موقفها انا في خاتمه
المطاف اتفق مع عذرا على المقاطعه ما دمت
قد اتيت عذرا على المقاطعه دكتور زيفرت ما
دمت قد اتيت على ذكر مساله العقوبات وكيف
انها مازالت مطروحه لكن المانيا في نهايه
المطاف اكدت انه ليس هناك نيه لفرض عقوبات
على تركيا في الوقت الراحن الراهن هل
تعتبر هذه رساله الى الاتراك ام رساله
موجهه الى بعض الاطراف داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي
نفسه اعتقد انها رساله موجهه الى الطرفين
الطبيعي ان المانيا لا تحبذ فرض عقوبات
على تركيا وما كنت اقوله انه قبل نحو
شهرين كانت هناك عقوبات ضد تركيا لكن على
مدان هذا ما اردت ان
اقوله تر المانيا تريد ان تمنح تركيا فرصه
وتريد لتركيا ان تنخرط مع اوروبا اكثر
وتعزز من العلاقات الاقتصاديه معها ونعلم
انه في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه كان هناك
محاولات لبحث اتفاقيه جمركيه بين اوروبا
وتركيا
وايضا كان هناك دعم لهذه الفكره لكن هذا
لا يعني ان الحكومه الالمانيه تدعم
المزاعم وادعاءات التركيه فيما يخص شرقيه
المتوسط سيد جوركان زنن في الاطار ذاته
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي من جانبه قال ان كل
الخيارات في التعامل مع تركيا مطروحه على
الطاوله اي رساله فهمتها انقره من هذا
الكلام في
رايك
اولا من وجهه نظر انقره انقره لا تتوقع اي
شيء يمكن ان يسمى بين مزدوجين عقوبات
والمانيا البلد الاقوى والاكثر اهميه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ويعلم تمام العلم اهميه
تركيا من حيث الطاقه وقضيه المهاجرين
والمواصلات والطاقه وما الى ذلك اذا
المانيا هي لاعب رئيسي في هذه القضيه لذا
نحن نفهم بان هم ليسوا على رغبه كبيره في
فرض عقوبات على تركيا في هذا اللقاء نعلم
ان القضيه ستث لكن لم تصدر اي تصريحات حتى
اللحظه من بروكسل لكن انقره لا تتوقع ايه
عقوبات حقيقه بسبب الموقف
الالماني ضيفكم من برلين محق بان الموقف
الالماني والفرنسي ليس مختلفين كثيرا حول
كثير من القضايا لكن المانيا هي اكثر وعيا
بمخاطر فرض ايه عقوبات لهذا السبب انقره
لا تتوقع اي عقوبات من اتحاد اوروبي تقوده
المانيا سالتك عن فهم برلين او تفسير
برلين لكلمات رئيس المجلس الاوروبي الذي
قال ان كل الخيارات في التعامل مع المانيا
مطروحه على
الطاوله ماذا تعني كلمه كل الخيارات هذه
مجرد
الكلمات ومن وجهه نظري انقره لا تعني اي
شيء
ملموس اي كل الخيارات هل يعني ذلك فرض
عقوبات اخر بيان صدر عن بروكسل لا ينم عن
اتخاذ قرار باتخاذ او فرض عقوبات ربما
ستكون القرارات قويه او البيان شديد
اللهجه لكن بالتاكيد لن تكون هناك عقوبات
التي من شانها ان تستوجب رده فعل من جانب
انقره اذا هذا التصريح مجرد دبلوماسي قد
يكون شديد اللهجه لكنه لا ينم عن احتمال
وقوع تداعيات ملموسه
عنه دكتور زيفرت سالتك عن كلام الرئيس
اردوغان بخصوص ان العلاقات الاوروبيه
التركيا تمر في هذه المرحله بامتحان ضخم
وكبير كيف تتوقع نتيجه هذا
الامتحان
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انها تعكس واقع الحال ونحن ومنذ
عامين تقريبا لدينا علاقات صعبه كاتحاد
اوروبي مع تركيا واخشى ان هذا الامر سوف
يستمر لان تركيا وكما تعلمون انه في الوقت
الذي كانت فيه تركيا مرشحه عضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي هي ما تزال مرشحه لكن نعرف ان
عمليه الانضمام
قد توقفت لنحو عامين
وتركيا لم يعد ذلك البلد الذي كان يطرق
على باب اوروبا وهو بلد يتبع سياسه خارجيه
مختلفه في احيان كثيره تتصادم مع مصالح
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا
نحن امام او في بدايات مرحله جديده من
العلاقات بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وتركيا
وسنرى على مدى العامين القادمين الكثيره
من الاسئله والتساؤلات التي تطرح والمصالح
تتضارب وال طبعا الحاجه الى التفاوض بشانه
بين الطرفين الاتحاد الاوروبي مستعد لذلك
لكن الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا
طبيعي يرفض ترشيح
البلد يهدد باستخدام القوه العسكريه او
يستخدمها كاداه ضغط وورقه رابحه في اي
مفاوضات هذا ايضا سينعكس في البيان الذي
نتوقعه عن بروكسل اعتقد ان البيان سيكون
قويا انا ايضا لا اتوقع فرض عقوبات لكنني
اتوقع رساله واضحه الى تركيا تقول ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي مستعد تعاون وتعزيز
التعاون السياسي لكنه في نفس الوقت سيفرض
خطوطا حمراء واضحه على تركيا ان لا
تتجاوزها لكي نتفادى المزيد من التفاقم في
العلاقه بين
الطرفين الا يشكل هذا ازدواجيه في التعامل
مع تركيا او تصادم في المواقف الاوروبيه
في التعامل مع تركيا مره في اروقه النيتو
يخرج المجتمعون او تخرج المفاوضات بنتيجه
تحث او باتفاق يبعث على التهدئه بينما
يمكن ان يصعد الاتحاد الاوروبي من الجانب
الاخر اليس في هذا ارباك بعض الشيء للمشهد
والسؤال للدكتور جونتر
ايضا اعتقد بالنسبه لي انا لا ارى ان هناك
ازدواجيه في المواقف لاننا يجب ان لا ننسى
ان هناك وض وضع راهن قائم في شرق المتوسط
بين تركيا واليونان وتركيا وقبرص تركيا هي
التي تريد تغيير هذا الوضع الراهن وتركيا
هي التي
استخدمت وجود قوه عسكريه او التهديد
باستخدام القوه لهذا السبب لا يمكن ان
تتعامل مع طرفين متنازعين احدهما يريد
تغيير الوضع الراهن القائم بمثل هذا النوع
واخر يريد المحافظ على الوضع الراهن لهذا
السبب ليس هناك ازدواجيه في المواقف بل
هناك محاولات لتخفيف حده التوتر لاقناع
الاطراف المتنازعه للدخول في تفاوض على
تركيا ان تجلس مع اليونان بدون ايه شروط
مسبقه هذا طبعا الموافقه على هذا كان
تطورا ايجابي
لكن في حاله عدم التوصل الى
اتفاق عن طريق التفاوض فاننا يجب ان
نذب عذرا على المقاطعه دكتور زوفر السؤال
لسيد كركان زنن يعني هل تعتقد ان تطاول
امد الصراع بين اذربيجان وارمينيا يمكن ان
يضعف موقف تركيا تجاه ازمه شرق
المتوسط
اعتقد ان هذا التطور لن يؤدي الى ايه
نتائج
ملموسه مثلا البيان الذي صدر عن نيتو ليس
بتلك الاهميه كما تفضلتم في البدايه قد
يقلل من احتمال حدوث دام العسكري بين
الاسطولين التابعين للبلدين لكنه لن ينهي
مطالب تركيا وحقوقها في ترسيم الحدود
البحريه والمناطق
الاقتصاديه الكل يتحدث عن التفاوض انقره
تقول انا مفتوحه على اي تفاوض حتى تركيا
اقترحت مؤتمرا اقليميا لكل البلدان
المتشاطئة
باجراء اين تق حدود بلد اين هي حدود
المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الحصريه هذا امر منطقي ان تجر
مثل هذه الحسابات الخبراء العلون
يمز لك على هذه المشاركه واعتذر عن
المقاطعه وكان معنا من برلين الدكتور
جونتر فرت رئيس مركز الدراسات التركيه
التطبيقيه بالمعهد الالماني للشؤون
الدوليه والامنيه شكرا جزيلا لكما
مشاهدينا الاعزاء في امان
الله
[موسيقى]